TODAY'S HEARING ON AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE -- IT'S FUNNY
THAT ON THE DAY WHEN ALL OF THE
CALL ALL OF THE COMMITTEE IS
HERE WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR MISSING
BECAUSE SHE IS CHAIRING.
A A HEARING RIGHT NOW IN A
CRITICAL MOMENT WHERE THERE IS --
AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION TAKING
PLACE SO WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD
AND ESTABLISH QUORUM -- AND THEN
WE WILL WAIT UNTIL OUR AUTHOR
GETS HERE.
MS ARE IN.
PRESENT [inaudible]
HOW?
WARNER HARD ROCK.
KALRA HERE LACKEY.
REYES HERE RUBIO [inaudible]
GREAT.
THANK YOU AND WE'LL WAIT FOR A
FEW MINUTES [inaudible]
A COMMON.
SO I ALWAYS.
MUSTER IN THAT'S WHAT THEY CALL
IT THE UNITED STATES NAVY.
WITH A YOU YO BECAUSE THAT'S WAY
SAILORS LINEUP AND MUSTER IN.
JUST SO YOU KNOW.
JUST FOR THAT I'D LIKE TO HAVE
ATTENDANCE TAKEN AGAIN BECAUSE
I'D LIKE.
TO AND DO WE HAVE SOMEBODY NEW
WITH US.
CHECK OUT WE'RE WE'RE JOINED BY
GIL GROSVENOR WHO'S THE
SPECIALIST SYSTEM TO THE SPEAKER.
ON ISSUES HAVING TO DO WITH
AGING AND LONG TERM CARE SO
THANK YOU FOR POINTING THAT OUT.
AND AND WILL HOPEFULLY BE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE HER FOR SOME TIME
UNTIL A MORE PERMANENT --
INDIVIDUAL IS -- SIGNED
-- YEAH
[inaudible]
BROTHER [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
WE WILL [inaudible]
WELCOME SENATOR.
THE CHURCH TAKE YOUR TAKE A
MOMENT WOULD YOU LIKE A CUP OF
WATER NO THANK YOU GLASS OF WINE
WOULD BE BETTER BUT NOT NOW.
I HEAR YOU.
I HEAR A SISTER OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE OF COURSE OF COURSE
FIRST UP IS -- WELL BOTH OF THE
BILLS ARE YOURS SO FEEL FREE
WHICHEVER ONE YOU WANT TO START
WELL WHY DON'T WE START WITH THE
SENIOR MASTER PLAN.
WHICH IS -- IN EXCITINGLY
AMBITIOUS AND LONG OVERDUE
MEASURE -- THAT WILL -- CREATE A
FRAMEWORK FOR A MASTER PLAN. FOR
AN AGING CALIFORNIA THAT
EMPOWERS ALL CALIFORNIANS TO AGE
WITH DIGNITY CHOICE AND
INDEPENDENCE.
NOT THAT IT'S ANYTHING I'M
PERSONALLY.
IN NEED OF RIGHT AT THE MOMENT
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS AN AGING STATE.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE FOUR
MILLION MORE SENIORS IN OUR
STATE BY TWENTY THIRTY AND WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY TOTALLY
UNPREPARED.
SO.
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA AS I MENTIONED.
ESTIMATED THIS NUMBER OF FOUR
MILLION ADDITIONAL SENIORS.
OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE BY.
TWENTY THIRTY ANY IMPLICATIONS
AFFECT NOT ONLY OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES BUT
ALSO THEIR FAMILIES.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL SO
STATE. 20% OF CALIFORNIA'S OLDER
ADULTS LIVE IN POVERTY AS WE
SPEAK.
AND THIS NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO
INCREASE WITH THE AGING OF OUR
STATE. 90% OF OLDER ADULTS WOULD
LIKE TO AGE IN THEIR HOMES AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S A SHOCKING
NUMBER I SUSPECT IT'S AT LEAST
90%.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE COMFORTABLE
THAT'S WERE WERE FAMILIAR THAT'S
WHAT WE KNOW THAT'S WHERE WE'VE
LIVED OUR NEIGHBORS OURFRIENDS
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE ALL RIGHT
THERE.
BUT OFTEN LACK OF ACCESS TO THE
NECESSARY SERVICES.
AND SUPPORT MAKE IT DIFFICULT IF
NOT POSSIBLE TO DO THAT.
WE'RE ALSO FACING UP.
THIS CREATES A CRISIS OF REALLY
IT.
ENORMOUS PROPORTIONS WERE
ALREADY IN NEGATIVE BIRTH RATE
STATE AND AS THE STATE AGES WE
NEED MORE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
FOR OLDER ADULTS.
BUT THE REALITY IS THE COST OF
LONG TERM CARE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS IS ON AFFORDABLE FOR
MOST CALIFORNIANS AND FRANKLY AS
WE TIGHTEN UP THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR IN HOME HEALTH SERVICES.
AS WE SHOULD THE COST TO ACCESS
THIS KIND OF HERE CARE BECOMES
EVEN MORE EXPENSIVE.
SO WE KNOW THE ANNUAL COST OF
THIRTY HOURS A WEEK OF HOME CARE.
IS ALMOST THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS THREE QUARTERS OF THE
STATE'S MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
THE MEDIAN ANNUAL COST OF
NURSING HOME CARE IS A WHOPPING
HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR WHICH IS MORE THAN TWICE --
THE STATE'S MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME AND ONLY 5% OF
CALIFORNIANS AGE FORTY AND OLDER
HAVE ACTUALLY EVEN PURCHASE
PRIVATE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
I IT'S NOT A VERY DESIRABLE
PRODUCT.
AND IT'S NOT VERY AFFORDABLE AND
YET.
WHEN PEOPLE AGE THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING THERE TO PROTECT THEM --
IN THAT.
IT IN THEIR LIVES SO -- ACROSS
THE STREET THE STATE OLDER
ADULTS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND FAMILIES RELY ON SERVICES
PROVIDED THROUGH MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES.
INCLUDING DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SOCIAL SERVICES AGING
REHABILITATION TRANSPORTATION I
MEAN IT'S THE GAMBIT EVERYTHING
YOU CAN THINK OF DOES HAVE AN
EFFECT AND IS NECESSARY IN
PARTICULAR GREATER LEVELS.
AS PEOPLE AGE THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO DRIVE THEY SHOULDN'T DRIVE
THEY HAVE HEALTHCARE ISSUES THEY
HAVE COGNITIVE ISSUES THEY HAVE
PHYSICAL IMPAIRMENTS.
THAT NOT ONLY ARE DISABILITY
COMMUNITY IN GENERAL BUT ALSO
MOBILITY ISSUES ALL THE THINGS
THAT HAPPEN AS WE AGE AND WE ARE
LIVING LONGER.
I JUST LOST MY MOTHER IN LAW IN
DECEMBER AT THE AGE OF ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR YEARS OLD -- SO --
AND THOSE ARE STORIES WE HEAR
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE LIVING
LONGER AND LONGER AND WE HAVE
THE INABILITY TO CARE FOR THEM.
SO DESPITE THE MANY PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES ADMINISTERED BY THE
RANGE OF THESE DEPARTMENTS.
FAMILY STRUGGLE TO WEAVE
TOGETHER SERVICES AND FINANCE
CARE IN THE HOPES OF HELPING
LOVED ONES REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES.
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO TURN FOR
HELP OR HOW TO PAY FOR SERVICES.
THAT WOULD HELP IS FINALLY FOUND
MANY PEOPLE ARE BOUNCE BETWEEN
PROGRAMS WITHOUT.
MUCH ASSURANCE THAT THOSE NEEDS
WILL BE MET.
WE NEED IS WE NEED A SENIOR
MASTER PLAN THAT IS DIRECTLY
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE GOVERNOR TO
LEAD THE STATE'S EFFORTS -- TO
TO READY US TO DEAL WITH THIS
AGING POPULATION WE HAVE ALL
THESE MULTIPLE SERVICES THEY
DON'T TALK TO EACH OTHER THEY
ARE COMMITTED IN ANY WAY SHAPE
OR FORM TO ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEMS OF OUR AGING POPULATION
PER SE.
THEY'RE ALL IN THEIR LITTLE
NATION THEY'RE ALL IN THEIR
LITTLE SILO AND YET THAT THE
NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE AS THEY AGE
ARE NOT SINGULAR. FOR MULTI
FACETED AND WE HAVE NO WAY TO
ACCOMMODATE THEM SO. TO TOGETHER
WITH THE TASK FORCE WHOSE
MEMBERS WILL BE APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE WE
HAVE A DIRECTOR TAP ASKED WITH
EVALUATING EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES WORKING ACROSS STATE
AGENCIES GOD FOR BID. TO ADDRESS
BOTTLENECKS PROGRAMMATIC --
SHORTFALLS IN NEEDS TO CREATE
SENIOR BASED HOUSING TO DEAL
WITH TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
HEALTHCARE ISSUES THE WHOLE
GAMBIT AND ALSO TO TO ALLOW
PEOPLE NOT ONLY TO AGE IN PLACE
BUT TO AGE WITH DIGNITY. TO BE
ABLE AND THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE WE
HEAR IN TALKING TO SENIORS AND I
THINK MY EXPERT YOU WILL CONFIRM
THIS THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN THAT
SENIORS HAVE HIS ISOLATION.
WE DON'T WANT THOSE PEOPLE HAVE
GIVEN THEIR LIVES TO RAISE THEIR
FAMILIES THEY PAY TAXES THEY'VE
BEEN CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY SOCIETY TO AGE ALONE.
THERE'S MORE THAT WE CAN DO WITH
THIS SETTING UP THIS MASTER PLAN
I THINK IS THE WAY TO DO THIS I
KNOW MY PREDECESSOR -- THAT MY
GOOD FRIEND CAROL LOU WORKED ON
THIS ISSUE SEVERAL YEARS AGO
IT'S NOT A NEW ISSUE IT WAS EVEN
SOMETHING THAT WAS RAISED PRIOR
TO THAT.
BUT WE ARE HERE FOLKS AND WE
HAVE GOT TO ADDRESSES PROCESS IN
THIS PROBLEM SO JOINING ME TODAY
BETSY BUTLER CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
ALONG WITH GARY PASS MORE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA.
THE CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA
SHOULD.
NEVER GOTTEN IT RIGHT THE
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS
ARE HERE TO TESTIFY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FIRST.
OKAY -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
GERMAN IS THERE IN A MEMBERS
IT'S A IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE MY NAME IS BETSY BY
LEARNING THE CHAIR OF THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING --
AGING VERY QUICKLY JUST HAVING
ANOTHER BIRTHDAY TWO WEEKS AGO
IT'S LIKE WOW I'M GETTING OLD
FAST BUT IT WOULD BE TO
ALTERNATIVE THEY SAY WELL THAT'S
WHAT THEY YEAH YEAH RIGHT -- SO
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
AGING IS VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT --
SB TWO TWENTY EIGHT IT'S VERY
MUCH NEEDED -- BILL AND WE'RE IN
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
AFFECT CHANGE ALL THE THINGS THE
SENATOR JUST MENTIONED I MEAN
THEY ALL ARE INTERRELATED INTER
RELATED -- AN AGING PERSON HAS A
LOT OF NEEDS IN THE STATE AND
THE POPULATION'S GOING SO MUCH
EVERY SINGLE DAY SO -- WE APPLY
THE SENATOR FOR YOUR LIFELONG
COMMITMENT -- TO HELPING OLDER
AMERICANS AND PARTICULARLY NOW
WITH THESE THESE VERY TENUOUS
TIMES FOR A NUMBER OF SENIORS --
FACING HOMELESSNESS OR ANY FOOD
IN SECURITY AND HEALTH CARE
CRISES SO -- I THINK A MASTER
PLAN WILL BE VERY HELPFUL IN
HELPING ARTICULATED DELINEATE
THE NEEDS OF THE HAVE A VERY
LARGE POPULATION HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- WE DID
THE COMMISSION ON AGING DID PUT
OUT A STATEMENT OF PRIORITIES
FOR THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING IT
TO GO TO THEM I KNOW WHEN TO ALL
MEMBERS HERE.
I DID GO TO THE GOVERNOR -- AND
IT PROVIDES -- OR ASKED.
FOR VERY IMPORTANT THINGS
INCLUDING PROVIDING INTEGRATED
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE MEDI
MEDICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDING EASY ACCESS TO
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND
INFORMATION -- SUPPORTING THE
VITAL ROLES OF PROFESSIONAL AND
FAMILY CARE GIVERS CARE GIVING
IS SUCH A HUGE ASPECT OF AGING
IN CALIFORNIA -- MOSTLY.
WOMEN WHO ARE PROVIDING THE
SERVICES TO AND LOW PAID
UNFORTUNATELY MOST OF THE TIME --
BUILDING MORE OLDER ADULT AND
MULTI AGE HOUSING --
INTERGENERATIONAL HOUSING AS WE
KNOW IT COMPLEMENTED BY AGE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES AND
TRANSPORTATION -- INSURING A A
QUALITY AGING SERVICES WORKFORCE --
BY EXPANDING GERONTOLOGY AND
GERIATRIC EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
ENHANCING CAREER PASSED WE KNOW
THAT.
THERE'S LITERALLY ONE
GERIATRICIAN FOR SEVENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THOSE NUMBERS ARE --
EVERY YEAR GROWING EXPONENTIALLY
AND AN INTEL WE REALLY COMMIT
FINANCES AND RESOURCES TO THESE
MATTERS ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
MORE GERIATRICIANS -- AND AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
OLDER PEOPLE IS IS WORSE IT'S
LIKE TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
PSYCHOLOGIST EVERY OLDER PERSON
OR TWENTY THOUSAND TO ONE
PSYCHOLOGIST SO IT'S IT'S VERY
CONCERNING.
PROTECTING OLDER ADULTS FROM IN
JUSTICE INCLUDING ABUSE FRAUD
AND DISCRIMINATION OF COURSE AS
A PRIORITY.
AND PROMOTING MORE ACCURATE
PERCEPTIONS.
OF THE POSITIVE POTENTIAL OF
LONGEVITY WE HAVE A LOT OF
WISDOM AS WE AGE AND AGEISM IS A
VERY SCARY THING -- SO GO AHEAD
SENATOR AND JUST FIX ALL THESE
PROBLEMS -- WITH THE GOVERNOR I
AM -- PARTICULARLY HEARTENED BY
THE FACT THERE'S BEEN NO NO
VOTES -- THUS FAR SO THERE'S NO
LINE ITEMS ON ANYTHING RIGHT YET
SO IT'S BUT WE'RE GETTING THERE
AND HOPEFULLY EVERYONE THE
COMMITTEE -- WILL BE SUPPORTIVE
AND AND WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THAT AS WELL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M GARY PASSED MORE
PRESIDENT OF THE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN THIS --
DISCUSSION WITH MY PERSONAL
THANKS TO SENATOR JACKSON.
FOR BEING ON THIS ISSUE AND
FOCUSING ON OUR PROBLEMS AND
NEEDS FOR MANY MANY YEARS I
PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN AT THIS JOB.
FOR JUST UNDER TWENTY YEARS
IT'LL BE TWENTY YEARS IN JANUARY
WHICH IS KIND OF MIND BLOWING IN
ITSELF.
AND I'VE ACTUALLY EXPERIENCE
SOME OF THE NEEDS FOR THESE
PROGRAMS SO I CAN SPEAK
PERSONALLY.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF MAKING
THEM AVAILABLE.
AS A STATE WE FIND OURSELVES IN
AN ODD SITUATION CALIFORNIA'S.
FOR DECADES BEEN CONSIDERED A
YOUNG STATE AND KIDS BUT OUR
MAIN FOCUS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE TIMING OF THE
BABY BOOMERS THE END OF THE
SECOND WORLD WAR ALL SHOWING UP
IN CALIFORNIA.
COMING FARMING FAMILY FAMILIES.
ALL THE FIRST UP.
REALITY THAT THEY CALL AS WAS A
DEMAND FOR PRIMARY SCHOOLS AND
SECONDARY SCHOOLS WITHIN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND THEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THEN THE FORMATION OF NEW
SUBURBS IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
NOW THEY ARE MY AGE THEY ARE
SEVENTIES.
AND THEY NEED HELP.
MANY OF THEM HAVE NOT PREPARED
PROPERLY.
AW MANY OF THEM CAN'T PREPARE
GIVEN THAT THE COST STRUCTURE
THAT WE FACE.
AND SO THIS GOVERNOR HAS.
OF VERY GENEROUSLY COMMITTED
HIMSELF TO FORMING.
A MASTER PLAN ON AGING AND I
THINK THAT THIS BILL.
BRINGS THE LEGISLATURE END OF
THAT PROCESS WHICH IT NEEDS TO
BE.
AS AN ADVOCATE LIVES SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF A DISCUSSION OF A
MASTER PLAN I FELT VERY STRONGLY
THAT WE NEED TO COMBINE BOTH THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
BUT ALSO LEGISLATIVE OUR CONCERN
AND INTEREST AND AWARENESS OF OF
OUR PROBLEMS AND NEEDS.
AND THIS BILL LAYS OUT WAYS TO
DO THAT -- THEY'LL BE A LITTLE
BIT OF FINE TUNING OF WHAT THIS.
BILL CONTAINS WITH WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
PROPOSES.
BUT I THINK THAT THAT'S
ACHIEVABLE.
AND WE WE ARE COMMITTED LIKE I
SAID IT'S BEEN TWENTY YEARS.
AND I CAN'T REMEMBER UP ANY ONE
OF THOSE YEARS WHEN I DIDN'T
DREAM OF TUESDAY.
UP OF OF COMING TOGETHER. TO
PLAN FOR WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN CALIFORNIA AND TO TAKE A
BROAD LOOK.
AT THE NEEDS OF OF AGING AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES WHO ARE
GROWING IN NUMBERS.
UP AND THAT.
I THINK WE GO BACK TO THE
SEVENTIES WHEN CALIFORNIA'S LAST
AN INNOVATOR IN PROVIDING AGING
SERVICES.
AND TOO OFTEN SINCE THEN WE HAVE
HELD ON TO CUT BACK -- BARELY
GOTTEN BY AND IT'S IT'S TIME.
TO TAKE A STAND AND TO PLAN.
AND TO BE WORKING TOGETHER TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF AT LEAST FOUR
MILLION NEW CALIFORNIANS SO THAT
THEY CAN.
GROW INTO THEIR GOLDEN YEARS IN
THE GOLDEN STATE.
WITH DIGNITY AND WITH A
PROSPERITY AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THE BILL.
UP AND IT'S ONE OF OUR IT'S ONE
OF OUR STRONG PRIORITIES AND
AGAIN THANK YOU -- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
UP.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON HEATHER
HARRISON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED LIVING ASSOCIATION IT'S
WONDERFUL TO SEE SO MUCH
MOMENTUM ON THIS ISSUE WHERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JENNIFER TANNEHILL WITH ERIN
READ MISTER SEE IT'S ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GARRETT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS HERE THIS AFTERNOON
ON BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LAUREN RALPH CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE IN SUPPORT --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ABOUT THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YES TERREL CLOSED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
GREAT ANY COMMENTS FROM.
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES MISERABLE.
SENATOR JACKSON THIS IS A SPOT
ON BILL GREATLY NEEDED I
SUPPORTED A 100%.
BUT I HAVE TO MAKE A CONFESSION.
I SPENT THIRTY NINE YEARS IN THE
INSURANCE BUSINESS IN ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN INSURANCE
COMPANIES DEVELOPED LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE.
I JUMPED ON IT -- I COULD NAME
OFF VARIOUS INSURANCE COMPANIES
THEY CAME OUT WITH EXCELLENT
PRODUCTS [inaudible]
WONDERFUL BENEFITS.
AND I WOULD HAVE BEEN PAID A TEN
OR 12% COMMISSION TO SELL IT.
SO I STARTED OUT LONG TERM CARE
SALES WITH RICH PEOPLE
[inaudible]
GETTING CARE.
THEN I WENT TO UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS [inaudible]
HEARING CARE.
SAME WAY WITH MIDDLE CLASS NO
DIDN'T THINK THEY NEEDED IT.
LOWER MIDDLE CLASS.
WELL NOW WE HAVE TROUBLE OF
FORTY NINE AND THEN I EVEN WENT
DOWN TO JUST REGULAR BLUE COLLAR
WORKERS THAT I KNEW MAN YOU'RE
IN TROUBLE IF YOU DON'T.
BUY THIS STUFF [inaudible]
NO.
SO LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE THE
PERCEPTION OF HUMAN BEINGS IS.
THEY DON'T NEED IT UNTIL THEY
NEEDED.
THEY DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR IT
AHEAD OF TIME [inaudible]
SO.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL FROM A
FEELING OF I DON'T KNOW HOW I
COULD PUT IT.
SOME OF FAILED CAPITALIST AT
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO STEP IN
ON THIS.
ONE AND SENATOR JACKSON IS.
LEADING THE WAY I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WILL COME OUT OF THIS
REPORT.
BUT I'M GONNA BE LOOKING AT IT
VERY CLOSELY BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
SILVER TSUNAMI HITTING THIS I'M
GOING TO BE SIXTY NINE YEARS OLD.
AND I DIDN'T BUY LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE BECAUSE BY THE TIME I
PERCEIVED I MIGHT NEED.
TO IT WAS TOO EXPENSIVE.
SO I'M JUST AS BAD AS MY CLIENTS.
SO THAT'S WHY SUPPORT YOUR BILL
AND I THANK GOD YOU HAVE IT.
THANK YOU OF THIS RACE.
I HAD A GOOD INSURANCE GUY I DID
BUY LONG TERM CARE.
THE NO NO REFLECTION ON YOU MY
DEAR MY DEAR.
NEIGHBOR.
I I DO WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR
I THINK THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ANY OF THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES FOR CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PLAN IS.
AND IT CAN'T JUST BE MISHMASH
AND DEAL YOU DO THIS AND YOU DO
THAT BECAUSE AS YOU'VE INDICATED
THEIR SILOS ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND EVERYBODY'S DOING THEIR
THEIR SHARE.
AND DOING WONDERFUL JOBS BUT
UNTIL WE SAY THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE WANT A MASTER
PLAN.
I APPRECIATED THAT THE GOVERNOR
IN HIS STATE OF THE STATE OF THE
STATE OR MAYBE WAS WHEN HE WAS
SWORN IN.
BUT WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT THIS --
I KNEW WAS IMPORTANT BEFORE I
KNEW IT WAS IMPORTANT THEN AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU WERE
THE ONE TAKING THE LEAD.
I KNOW LAST YEAR WE TALKED ABOUT
IT AND WE'LL RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT WAS I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR FOR DOING THIS.
AND FOR PUTTING TOGETHER THE
BASICALLY WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO DO IT AND IN THAT REGARD.
I HAVE ASKED ALSO TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF YOUR BILL I WOULD LIKE
TO BE PART OF THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
CERTAIN [inaudible]
GREAT.
YES THE SERVICE THAT I WON ON IT
ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE CAN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT IS THAT?
OKAY THANK YOU. FOUR FIVE YES
SIR I THINK AT THIS POINT THE
ONLY ONES LEFT OUT ARE OF MISS
CALL MISTER KALRA IS ALREADY ON
MISTER LACKEY AND MYSELF.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M I'M I THINK I JOINED ALREADY
BUT IF NOT I'M HAPPY TO JOIN AS
WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IT'S A GREAT BILL
IT'S A TIMELY BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
ALSO TO HAVE ITS OWN VEHICLE.
AS THE AS THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH TRYING TO FLESH OUT ITS
PROPOSAL NOW SO -- I THINK IT'S
IT'S OF AB IT BOTH MAINTAINS
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WELL AS HELPS
OFFER COMPLIMENTING VIEW POINTS
AS WELL.
SO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU -- AND THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ACCOMPLISHING THE GOALS AT
HAND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS IMPORTANT AND TIMELY BILL.
SIR BILL ENJOYS A DO PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES -- I
BELIEVE THERE WAS A FIRST BY
MISS MISS RUBIO AND A SECOND BY.
MS BERNARD **** BATH LET'S CALL
THE ROLL.
SB TWO TWO EIGHT MS IRAN HI MS
ARE IN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WARNER HER VIA.
WARNER HORROR ROTH AYE KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES AYE REYES AYE.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSES.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THEY WANT TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
.
TWO EIGHTY OKAY.
SO I'VE BEEN ASKED TO BE QUICK
ON THE NEXT ITEM AND I CERTAINLY
I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT I DID
WANT TO SORT OF FRAME THIS.
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THERE ARE
EASY FIXES OR IT'S EASY EASIER
WAYS TO ADDRESS PROBLEMS.
AND THIS BILL IT REFLECTS ONE OF
THE EASIER WAYS TO DEAL.
AGAIN WITH SENIORS AND WITH OUR
DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
BY TRYING TO DO PREVENTION.
IT'S ALWAYS WORTH A POUND OF
CURE I DON'T KNOW IF YOUNG
PEOPLE SAY THAT ANYMORE BUT I
REMEMBER HEARING IT AT HOME
QUITE REGULARLY AS A KID GROWING
UP.
THIS MEASURE SB TWO EIGHTY IS
THE DIGNITY AT HOME ACT IT SEEKS
TO ALLOW MORE SENIORS AND
DISABLED PEOPLE TO AGE IN PLACE
AND STAY IN THEIR OWN HOMES
THROUGH THE USE.
OF HOME MODIFICATIONS TO HELP
REDUCE THE RISK OF FALLING.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS ON PEOPLE WHO ARE --
COMING TO EMERGENCY ROOMS
PARTICULARLY SENIORS AT LEAST
THE THIRD IF NOT MORE ARE
PRESENTED EMERGENCY ROOMS
BECAUSE OF FALLS IN THEIR HOME.
USUALLY IN THE BATHROOM.
USUALLY IN THE SHOWER.
WE HAVE GRAB OURS THERE ARE HE
VERY SIMPLE METHOD TO HELP
PEOPLE WHOSE WHO ARE LOSING
THEIR BALANCE OR WHO ARE
SLIPPING IN WHAT IS OTHERWISE IT
A KIND OF CHALLENGING.
ENVIRONMENT TO KEEP THEM FROM
FALLING BECAUSE WHEN THEY FALL
THEY HURT THEMSELVES THEY HURT
THEMSELVES DRAMATICALLY TO THE
POINT WHERE MANY SENIORS.
WHO FALL AND HAD A PRESENTED
HOSPITALS DON'T EVER GET TO GO
BACK HOME?
WELL THAT SEEMS RIDICULOUS IF WE
CAN DO SIMPLE MEASURES LIKE GRAB
BARS OR HAVING PEOPLE FROM THE
AREA AGENCY ON AGING -- GET
GRANTS WHICH WE SEE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET TO HELP
WITH THAT NOW GIVING MONEY TO
THESE FOLKS TO GO IN AND TO
INSPECT PEOPLE'S HOME
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T OTHERWISE NECESSARILY
AFFORD TO GRAB BAR. TO GO IN AND
INSPECT THE HOME AND SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT.
YOU'VE GOT A RUG OVER HERE LET'S
TAKE A HAMMER AND A NAIL A NAIL
IT DOWN SO YOU DON'T TRIP.
YOU NEED A BAR YOU NEED A HIGHER
LEVEL TORRENT YOU NEED A A GRAB
BAR IN THE SHOWER THESE ARE
RELATIVELY SIMPLE THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO. TO HELP OUR SENIORS SO
THAT THEY DON'T FALL.
BECAUSE FALLS CAN BE SIGNIFICANT
AND ALSO FOR OUR DISABILITY
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
IN A CHAIR.
IT'S HARD TO GET THROUGH A
DOORWAY THAT DOESN'T ACCOMMODATE
YOU BUT YOU WANT TO STAY AT HOME
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO STAY HOME
BECAUSE FRANKLY THERE'S REALLY
NOT TOO MANY OTHER OPTIONS.
SO THIS IS A BILL WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE BUILDING
COMMUNITY AND AND I THINK AT
THIS POINT TIME THERE CERTAINLY
OFF THEIR OPPOSITION I WANT TO
BRING THEM ALONG TOO BECAUSE
THIS IS A KIND OF THING WE
SHOULD BE DOING FOR FOLKS SO --
I THINK THAT THIS IS A A SORT OF
A NO BRAINER KIND BILL WE GOT
MONEY IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
FORD -- WILL PUT THE MONEY IN
THE PROCESS TOGETHER AND WILL
HELP A LOT OF SENIORS AND A LOT
OF OUR DISABLED COMMUNITY BE
ABLE TO STAY AT HOME.
IT'S SAFER IT'S BETTER IT'S LESS
EXPENSIVE FOR ALL OF US AND IT'S
IT'S THE KIND OF THING WHERE
COMPASSION COMMONSENSE COME
TOGETHER SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
HI HERO.
YET YOU SAID IT ALL FOR ME
[inaudible]
BUT BETTER.
MY NAME IS DONNA MILO.
AND I AM REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL MS SOCIETY.
THIS IS A MESS BOYCE IT'S THE
BEST.
WE GET.
<c.cyan>G.</c>
I WAS LUCKY TO BE DIAGNOSED AT
THE AGE OF SIXTY WITH THE
DISEASE THAT.
USUALLY HITS THE YOUNG.
UNFORTUNATELY BY THE TIME I WAS
DIAGNOSED.
I WAS SECONDARY PROGRESSIVE.
AS BAD AS IT GETS.
AND I PROGRESS RAPIDLY.
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS AFFECTS
MUSCLE STRAIN BALANCE
COORDINATION.
ALL OF THE WHICH MAKE THE FALLS.
A TO FREQUENT EVENT.
MY WORST FALL.
A BROKE EVERY TO ON MY LEFT FOOT
[inaudible]
AGAIN LUCKY.
COULD HAVE BEEN ONE OF MY HANDS.
OVER THE YEARS.
WE'VE.
BEEN ABLE TO DO A A NUMBER OF
THINGS. TO OUR HOME SO THAT WE
CAN STAY THERE.
WE PUT GRAB BARS ON THE TOILET.
GRAB BARS ON THE WALL IN THE
BATHROOM.
SMALL RUBBER RAMPS TO GET OVER
THE THRESHOLD AT THE FRONT DOOR.
AGAIN LUCKY NO SCARES.
A BAD CASE.
THAT I CAN HOLD ON TO TO CHANGE
POSITIONS.
IT HOLDS MY STUFF [inaudible]
REMOTE PHONE -- IT KEEPS ME FROM
FALLING OUT OF BED.
MY PERSONAL FAVORITE.
SWING AWAY DOOR HINGES.
SO THAT I CAN GET INTO.
THE BEDROOMS AND BATHROOMS IN MY
OWN HOME.
THESE MINOR AIDS ALLOW ME TO
MAINTAIN MY QUALITY OF LIFE.
AND TO REMAIN ACTIVE IN MY
COMMUNITY.
LIKE VOLUNTEERING AT THE ZOO.
THE FINANCIAL COST.
OF CRIME DISEASES.
DISABILITIES AND OLD FOLKS
[inaudible]
OLDER FOLKS.
ALL OF WHOM I REPRESENT
[inaudible]
CAN BE -- REYES.
YOU SPEND ALL OF YOUR AVAILABLE
CASH.
YOU SPEND ALL OF YOUR SAVINGS.
YOU START DRAWING DOWN ON YOUR
RETIREMENT.
IF YOU HAVE ANY.
FINALLY YOU DEPEND ON THE
KINDNESS OF STRANGERS.
WITH THE HOUSING.
MEDICAID AND SSJ.
I HAVE SEVERAL FRIENDS.
IN THAT LAST GROUP.
WHO COULD REALLY BENEFIT?
FROM THE WONDERFUL PROGRAM
YOU'RE OFFERING.
IF THEY KNOW ABOUT IT.
I BELIEVE THAT SB.
TWO EIGHTY WOULD BE.
A REAL GIFT FOR THEM.
I SINCERELY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS PROGRAM.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND I HAVE TO SAY I WE BOTH HAVE
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S LAUREN RALPH AND I'M A
SENIOR SIMPLY MEMBER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR -- LEGISLATURE.
FOR NAPA SOLANO AND DOWN.
HI.
ORIGINALLY WROTE THE PROPOSAL OR
A PROPOSAL FOR THIS BILL AND
SENATOR JACKSON PICKED IT UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT --
MY MY FIRST INTEREST IN FALLS
PREVENTION CAME BECAUSE MY STEP
MOM.
FELL.
AND SHATTERED HER FEMUR.
AND SHE LIVED IN AN OLDER HOME --
AND SHE HAD TO GO TO A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY.
AND EVEN AFTER SHE WAS ABLE TO
GET INTO A WHEELCHAIR.
AND MOVE AROUND YOU KNOW SO THAT
SHE COULD.
OF POTENTIALLY LIVE AT HOME SHE
COULDN'T COME HOME BECAUSE HER
HOME DIDN'T ALLOW HER TO GET
INTO IT IN A WHEELCHAIR.
SHE WAS A VERY LARGE WOMAN AND
SHE COULDN'T THE CHAIR WOULD NOT
FIT IN.
AND I COULDN'T BRING HER INTO MY
HOME BECAUSE I CHAIR WOULDN'T
FIT IN I CAN'T GET THE CHAIR IS
MEDITECH NONE OF MY FRIENDS.
WHO USE CHAIRS CAN GET INTO MY
HOME WHICH IS KIND OF AN
EMBARRASSING THING TO ME BUT I
CAN'T AFFORD TO REBUILD MY HOME?
SO CALIFORNIA HAS TO IMPENDING
CRISIS ONE IS THE LACK OF
HOUSING THAT'S AFFORDABLE FOR
YOUNG AND OLD CALIFORNIANS.
AND THE SECOND IS HOW WE PAY FOR
MEDICAL HOME CARE NEEDS OF OUR
SENIOR POPULATION.
BY TWO THOUSAND THIRTY THE
SENIOR POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA
WILL -- WELL WE ALREADY HEARD
THAT INCREASED BY MORE THAN FOUR
MILLION.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT BY TWENTY
TWENTY THE ANNUAL AN INDIRECT
COSTS THE FALLS IS EXPECTED TO
REACH FIFTY FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION.
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE COST WILL
BE BORNE BY MEDICARE AND MEDI
CAL.
GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S NEED TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE AVAILABLE
HOUSING IT'S A PERFECT TIME FOR
THE STATE TO MAKE THAT HOUSING
MORE AGING DISABILITY FRIENDLY.
BY INCORPORATING FALLS
PREVENTION OR SPECIFIC
ACCESSIBLE FEATURES INTO THE
STATE BUILDING STANDARDS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA HOUSING.
MAKING THESE CHANGES WILL ALLOW
RESIDENTS TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES
AS THEY AGE AND ALLOW FAMILIES
TO EASILY BRING THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS ELDER OR OR DISABLED
INTO THEIR HOMES.
AS THEY NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
POLICY FEATURED CAN BE MUCH LESS
COSTLY WHEN BUILT INTO THE
ORIGINAL DESIGN OF THE HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT AND INDIVIDUAL HOMES
RATHER THAN RETROFITTING
EXISTING HOMES.
THE REQUESTED FEATURES IN SB TWO
EIGHTY WILL NOT SIGNIFICANTLY
CHANGE THE LOOK OR THE COST OF
BUILDING THE HOUSE.
CREATING FOR EVER HOMES FOR
CALIFORNIANS CAN ALSO PRESERVE
WEALTH SO THAT CALIFORNIANS WILL
BE ABLE TO SAVE MONEY AS THEY
AGE.
BY NOT HAVING TO MOVE WHEN THEIR
PHYSICAL ABILITIES BECOME
REDUCED AND HAVE THE RESOURCE TO
HAVE THE HELP THAT THEY NEED AS
THEY AGE.
IN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO MAKE SMART
DECISIONS.
ABOUT CREATING HOUSING THAT
LASTS FOR SENIORS.
FAMILIES AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES THANK YOU.
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT.
YES MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
BOB ROEMER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WHY ARE FORMER POSITION IS
NEUTRAL I THINK IT SHOULD BE
NOTED WE WERE ORIGINALLY HAD
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
IN ITS EARLIEST FORM WE WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF IN THE
SPONSORS THE ADDRESSED ALL OF
OUR ISSUES ALLOWING US TO GO
NEUTRAL -- IN JUST A MATTER OF
MONTHS -- WILL BE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING -- TO
BASICALLY REQUIRE GRAB BAR
SUPPORT BACKING IN ALL BATHROOMS
OF ALL NEW HOMES.
ARE HAVING AT LEAST ONE WIDER A
BEDROOM DOOR ONE WIDER BATHROOM
DOOR -- THESE ARE RELATIVELY LOW
COST THINGS THAT WE CAN PUT INTO
ALL NEW CONSTRUCTION OF FOR THE
FUTURE SO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL.
YES THERE ARE CATCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING THE SENATORS
CORRECT THIS IS A NO BRAINER.
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT HERE
AGENCIES ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
STEPPING UP AND BEING PART OF OF
TAKING THIS OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
TELLING THE ASSESSMENTS HELPING
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT IS
NEEDED. FOR INDIVIDUALS TO BILLS
STAY IN THEIR HOME SO WE THANK
THE SENATOR FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GARY PASSED MORE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
LET ME TAKE JUST ONE SECOND OF
FIVE MILLION TELL YOU MY
PERSONAL STORY ABOUT FALLS --
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO I
WAS RUSHING INTO THIS BUILDING
ON THE SOUTH SIDE.
COMING UP THE SIDEWALK.
AND I FELT.
AW AND I FELT RIGHT DOWN ON MY
FACE.
AND ALL AFTER ABOUT AN HOUR OF
HAVING PEOPLE HELP ME AND GIVE
ME PULL TOGETHER AN AMBULANCE
CAME AND PICKED ME UP I WENT TO
THE ER.
AND DISCOVERED THAT I HAD FOR
STROKES IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
AND COULD EASILY HAVE DIED.
AND MY HEART STOPPED AT SOME
POINT.
ALL OF WHICH IS A LONG LONG WAY
OF DESCRIBING THE REHAB THAT I
HAVE UNDERGONE.
THE AMOUNT OF EFFORT AND IT WAS
ALL AS A RESULT OF THAT FALL.
AND AND I LITERALLY FALL ABOUT
ONCE EVERY TWO WEEKS JUST NOW
JUST TRYING TO NEGOTIATE.
AND IT'S FRIGHTENING AND IT
NEEDS TO BE I NEED HELP WITH IT
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT SO I
THANK THIS CENTER.
FOR AGAIN COMING FORWARD AND
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
SOMETHING SO IMPORTANT PEOPLE
LIKE ME THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS LIKE TO THINK THE
SENATOR FROM HER MULTI YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE --
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- BRINGING BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
NOW.
GREAT WELL -- THIS DOES ENJOY DO
PASSED TO ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
SPEND MOTION BY MISS RUBIO
SECONDED BY MISTER VOEPEL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK AND
THANK YOU ALSO FOR ADVOCATING
AND RECEIVING THE FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET THAT WILL GO A VERY LONG
WAY.
AND STARTING THIS PROGRAM
STARTING THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
THEN -- MAYBE IN FUTURE YEARS WE
CAN BE WORKING ON ENSURING THAT
WE ONLY INCREASE CONTINUE
INCREASING THAT FUNDING SO THAT --
AGENCIES AREN'T -- RESTRICTED BY
THE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND CAP
BUT CAN ACTUALLY HELPFUL FILLED
GREATER NEEDS WITH THE GROWING
POPULATION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK.
WE OPEN THE DOOR AND THEY WILL
SEE MY GOODNESS THE VALUE FOR
THE DOLLAR.
IS ENORMOUS -- FOR EVERY DOLLAR
WE SPEND I SUSPECT WE SAVE.
MANY FOLD IN PEOPLE NOT HAVING
TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL NOT HAVING
TO BE IN NURSING HOMES -- GO
THROUGH REHABILITATION I JUST
THINK AGAIN IT'S IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHERE WE'RE
OTHERWISE PENNY WISE AND POUND
FOOLISH BUT THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
THAT EFFORT THANK YOU GREAT
CLOSE WITH THAT ROLL CALL PLEASE.
SB TWO EIGHTY NAZARIAN.
IS ARE IN I'D VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I MOURN HER VIA. FOR FOR
NO FOUR FIVE I'D KALRA.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT CHECK KALRA
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES.
REYES I LOCAL RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSED.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
TOP AGAIN